KATE BISHOP
Can I tell you a secret?
I'm working with an Avenger.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Oh my gosh, whoa, we are right in front of
Grand Central Station in
beautiful New York City.
Day 4 on Hawkeye. I mean, it is already...
Everything happened very quickly.
Archery lessons, training in LA
on the stunt side of things,
hand-to-hand combat. I love that this job
left me no excuse but to get to a place
where I could come here and be
shown something and I would
be able to pick up on it quickly.
BERT
The kind of hook for us was bringing a
female superhero, that it's not about
being superhuman, it's about being
super skilled,
and funny as anything.
RHYS THOMAS
We knew we wanted to contrast
her with Clint. You know, they're the
classic buddy cop sort of energy,
of these two divergent
personalities, kind of, meeting.
KATE BISHOP
It's pretty cool to me.
CLINT BARTON
People are trying to kill us.
KATE BISHOP
Actually, it's pretty bad
when you think about it.
JEREMY RENNER
Hailee Steinfeld is just wonderful.
She's a very, very talented actress.
[Grunt]
KATE BISHOP
Didn't realize we were supposed to
bring guns.
JEREMY RENNER
I begrudgingly, sort of, have her as a
partner and then our
friendship grows through it,
and a lot of wonderful
and fun things transpire.
[Laughing]
ELEANOR BISHOP
So, Kate is helping you
with an Avengers level threat?
KATE BISHOP
He's my partner.
CLINT BARTON
That's kind of a stretch.
VERA FARMIGA
She's really adept at digging deep
and mining and just adding so much
dimension. What Hailee's done with
this character, I think fans
are just gonna eat her up.
KATE BISHOP
We're saving the holidays.
HAILEE STEINFELD
I'm just so excited to be a
part of the MCU, I've had an amazing time
and I just feel very lucky to be here
right now, and I'm
excited to see what happens.
KATE BISHOP
Holy sh—
There are arrows
more dangerous than that one?